let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
friday
[Music]
friday friday friday
[Music]
coming towards the end of the week
you know what that means here on the
tony michael's podcast
we air every single weekday monday
through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific but
on fridays
it's a special day on fridays
because here on the tony michaels
podcast on fridays we go through your
vote on the bonehead of the week poll
that's right you go vote we break it
down every single friday in the second
hour
of the tony michaels podcast
me and my co-host and executive producer
gabe sanchez
rail on and rake through
who you choose to be the bonehead of the
week so don't forget to go follow us on
twitter at tonymichaelspod so every
single week you can vote for bonehead of
the week
and then we break down your vote on the
tony michaels podcast
every single friday and we air every
single weekday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific on youtube twitter
and twitch and now the midas touch
facebook page so give us a like over
there on facebook on the books of face
we air on the minus touch facebook page
every single weekday we are on youtube
subscribe and you can participate in the
super chat come on over to youtube folks
if you're on twitter twitch
maybe facebook you come over to youtube
you can participate in the super chat
don't forget to subscribe to the youtube
channel why you're here
do all the things that you're supposed
to do you know like comment
put the bell notification all the stuff
you're you know i'm supposed to
all the things youtube things i'm
supposed to say whatever those are you
go ahead and do those good morning
everyone good
morning
good friday morning it's gonna be a
great weekend
i think
surely there'll be uh plenty of news
there was plenty of news this week
there's plenty news this morning uh
looks like we have several things to
talk about today i have a special
guest today she's gonna pop in you guys
know rachel bittikoffer
the the world-renowned political
strategist
fantastic fantastic
on messaging so we're gonna get the
breakdown of the week because boy there
was a lot of news this week
we had the uh kevin mccarthy tapes we
had the
marjorie perjury green
from last friday it's been a week since
we spent a week since we streamed eight
hours the marjorie taylor green
insurrection hearing we know she now
perjured herself
with the uh
marshall marshall's law
the store marshalls law
oh boy oh boy van jones stepped in it
this morning and of course the right to
far right and the far left are battling
it out on the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends
and ozark is trending apparently uh the
netflix series ozark is dropping a new
part of the series
and that has nothing to do with politics
but
i'm from where that show is set so maybe
we'll talk about ozark here today the
main thing we're going to do is we're
going to talk to rachel bittikoffer here
in just a few minutes
about the incoming news
of the lunacy that is the gqp the far
right
also i think gabe's gonna give us a
little bit of a breakdown
on any kind of new news
anything that's brand new out there with
the uh elon musk pretending to buy
twitter that's right he's pretending to
buy twitter everyone's like tony sold
like eight billion dollars in tesla
stock yeah well that i i really actually
don't see that as good for him or tesla
and if it's not good for him or tesla
it's probably not a good idea for the
banks to bet on elon musk
to run twitter if he can't figure out
how to run tesla which is a much more
profitable company than what twitter is
what in the [ __ ]
like why would if i'm a bank right if
you're a bank
and you're betting on something you're
doing a risk assessment
and the guy the guy that you're supposed
to take the risk with
is just out there flinging [ __ ] all over
the place making all kinds of horrible
bad decisions when it comes to i don't
know like money
the other thing too is the word is is
that
the debt that he's gonna carry on this
thing
the profits that twitter would have
would not service that debt
so in other words he's going to have to
have a paywall somehow on [ __ ]
twitter
which
will make users leave the platform why
do you think peop why do you think
facebook and twitter are the biggest
platforms because
we pay them in our data
that's right you you
twitter's not free facebook is not free
we pay them in exchange for our data
that's the exchange right
you have to give them something and they
give you something well they exchange
your data to sell it to advertisers to
sell you ads it's the whole [ __ ]
point
that's how they monetize it now facebook
facebook is is a much more complex
platform and they own several different
other social media companies so yes
they're more profitable than twitter
but twitter some could argue is maybe
more important than
in the sphere of freedom of speech you
know that's what the far right says
oh i seen a meme the other day
tom powell jr posted it on instagram and
i put it on my uh
my twitter page a screenshot of it maybe
maybe i'll show you uh
what i posted up for all the elon stands
out there
they've been all over my [ __ ] since
we've been dogging on elon oh [ __ ]
they're everywhere these [ __ ] elon
stands have the elon stands been in your
account too holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're everywhere
it's almost like it's almost like elon
has a bot machine somewhere
these people can't like that rube that
much right come on i mean i guess
there's plenty of rooms to like other
rubes you know but i mean god damn
these people act like this guy's a god
it's really it's really it's [ __ ] you
know what's that you know what said
the venn diagram of of elon stands
is just like a complete circle of the of
the trump stands the trumpers on these
social media sites holy [ __ ]
one and the same these people think they
are
good morning to everyone uh ken is here
andrea's here cindy's here margie's here
mj is here good morning marty from
facebook janie from facebook amanda's
here robin's here
well kalin's here
debbie from salt lake is here mary
deanna edith from facebook is here liz
from facebook is here
uh mayo is here good morning mayo
cindy is here
you guys just keep coming back and
coming back and coming back i love it
thank you for all the new listeners out
there if you guys if you guys are new
listeners
listen up we air this show every single
weekday monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific two
hours every single weekday two whole
hours
and on friday this is a special treat
if you're here on friday because in the
second hour we go through your vote on
the bonehead of the week poll
on the second hour of every friday so
today you're gonna get to watch the
bonehead of the week now here's the
other thing that i'll give you if you
are a new listener
go to our youtube page and subscribe and
the reason why you want to do that is
because if you miss anything anything at
all it does not matter it's all over on
the youtube channel we even cut out
clips of the show our favorite clips
some of the best clips some of the clips
that you guys like the most we clip them
out put them on the youtube channel
we also put bonehead of the week and
another special thing that we're gonna
do for you here in the next in the
coming weeks is every saturday we're
gonna air a best of
the show so on saturday you'll have i
don't know it'll be about in 30 minutes
to 45 minutes maybe an hour something
like that
it'll be the best of clips of the show
all in one spot so you just be able to
click on one
one link one youtube video
and get the lowdown of the week the best
of the week we're trying to figure out
what we call it best of makes sense
though doesn't it
i think it makes sense and then we'll
air bonehead of the week every single
sunday i think we played around with
times but i think sunday we're going to
pick out a time that airs every single
sunday
and we'll air it on the youtube twitter
twitch and the facebook minus touch
facebook page
we'll air it across all the channels
just been experimenting with it but i
think we're just gonna commit to this
and just let you guys watch any of the
comments or any of the content that you
that you want just go over to the
youtube channel and subscribe right now
if you're on facebook
here's good news if you're on facebook
the mind is such facebook page the link
is right there in the post you just
click that and come on over to youtube
get in the super chat
and you can subscribe to the
the youtube channel
holy moly do we have some news this week
um
marjory taylor green you guys know where
we we put marge marge is on the bone end
of the week poll so is elon and so is
laura ingraham uh laura ingraham
and i don't want to get into it too much
laura ingraham made her mom work to pay
off her debts holy [ __ ]
it's not surprising is it that laura
would make her mom work to pay off her
debts
i mean i i'm not surprised by this her
dad was a nazi you remember on the minus
touch uh podcast her brother went on the
minus touch podcast and said her dad had
mine comp on the coffee table or
bookshelf or something i don't know
[ __ ]
she's a nazi it's not surprising she
would force her mother
to work to pay off her debts holy [ __ ]
uh
the other news that we have is this
jamie raskin video have you guys seen
this video of jamie raskin asked
absolutely burning down the house of
marjory t the green
holy [ __ ] some [ __ ] is what i said
just burns her down and then they try to
they try to strike
they tried to strike
the
the uh
comments from the record
and on the house floor that jamie
ranskin when he burns down
marge's house
uh someone's pointing out here
we have a birthday uh minus robin has a
birthday
uh looks like everyone's saying hey
everyone say happy birthday
to midas robin midas robin
is a big fan here
at the tony michaels podcast we always
love to have robin robin thank you very
much for being here every single weekday
robin is always here robin is always
sending us great content too thank you
robin and i would encourage all of you
out there tag us in any post tag us if
you want us to see something cause we
don't always see everything i mean i
can't see everything on twitter jesus
christ i'm not elon musk and his bots i
mean how am i supposed to know
everything that goes on on twitter
i mean i can't i can't even put cocaine
back in coca-cola for crying out loud
how am i supposed to see everything
that's on the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends i try folks i try but if
you want me to see something if you want
me to see something send us tag me gabe
the podcast
robin does a great job of it and thank
you very much robin thank you thank you
so much
for being a fan of the show we love
having you
and happy
birthday happy birthday to you
thank you thank you thank you we have a
great a great commentator and one of the
world-renowned political strategists
that is going to join us dr doc rach
rachel
bitte copper is going to join us
we're super excited to have rachel here
so let's do this let's take a break and
we when we come back
we will have dr rachel bittikoffer with
us don't go anywhere stay right there we
will be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking to the break i
played that break because i know that's
one of
doc's
favorite videos i know she loves the
letters from the trucker convoy
so i want i wanted to play her favorite
favorite uh satire video there of ours
good morning rachel how are you
what's happening
oh man there is a lot of there's a big
pile of [ __ ] to go through with these lg
peers this week i mean ever since ever
since marjorie taylor green took the
stand um we know that now her name is
her i i call her marjory hoof foot green
but now we know it's marjorie perjury
green we have madison cawthorne who
oh can't stop rolling through a big pile
of dogs yet excuse the expression um and
then i have a video that i want to play
for you that i seen this morning
and you you know senator kennedy down in
louisiana this this it just
he he he deems people on the left as
wokers have you heard this
yes oh my god i i want to show you this
because
it's so weird
it's so weird but let me let me play it
real quick because i i love i love i
actually love how he says this he's
trying to be funny yeah um but what he's
doing is he's he's walking right right
into the point but let's listen
twitter is run
by wokers wokers represent the crank
wing of the democratic party
uh wokers as i've said before easy to
recognize most of them uh eat food
only fit for rabbits now we we know we
know rachel that that that the
republicans are completely terrified of
fruit and vegetables this week because
the pres the former president united
states the cheeto dust mobster grandpa
poopy pants donald trump is deathly
afraid he even even swore under oath
that he's terrified of killer tomatoes
no so it's not surprising
this is crazy right why why why do we
have to
play this kind of stuff in this
political discourse have they really
fallen this far excuse the expression
from the apple tree i mean is that is it
is that what's going on what the hell is
going on here
yeah i mean you know this is a party
that
i think also in the news this week was
me trying to remind people like this is
not the same republican party that was
in office 10 years ago almost right all
of the crazy conservatives from 10 years
ago got replaced by people who were bat
[ __ ] [ __ ] nuts they got broken
logical primaries something that you've
never seen on the left you see
one exception right aoc beating crawly
out and that um you know you catch an
incumbent with their pants down like uh
david brat caught eric cantor on the
other side it can happen right right
um so um but yeah but we watched
2010 2012 2014
um and 2016
wash out
really everybody who had been like in
the conservative caucus that newt
gingrich ran okay right right right from
the back
back in the early 90s when they were
trying to run the great american plan i
forget what the hell it was but you know
that was their grand scheme right yeah
yeah and like here's a here's a really
good way to encapsulate this okay and
like you can literally watch like their
moderates get purged by ideological
extremism in these nominate these
ideology scores that we have for members
of congress that are particularly good
measurements right so you can watch that
happen but you also see
moderate dems like the blue dog caucus
in the south in 2014 get wiped out and
they get replaced moderate dems that are
like you know right in the center
replaced with ideologues like tom cotton
okay right right and then you see
somebody like rubio when he ran in 2010
he was a tea party i mean i think it was
2010 might have been 2014 but pretty
sure it was 2010. he came in as a tea
party
yo guy david jolly was supposed to run
in that that race
or run against rubio and uh yeah i'm
mixing that up so anyway yeah rubio
comes in and he's the tea party like
he's part of the young guns caucus right
and now
like if you asked the crazy caucus the
coup caucus which is not a small group
of people if rubio's in the club they'd
be like oh hell no he's total
establishment dude okay so like this guy
that was once so ideological
that he was on in the tea party
rebellion is now considered what we
would call a sane republican today
right right
well you know what let me finish up the
video here because what he says like
they try to be populist but like eating
vegetables eating salad is somehow not
cool anymore like it's woke to eat salad
i and honestly i eat you eat meat right
i i mean i do i was a vegetarian for
four years why did you forget those
thanksgiving turkeys back so don't do
that [ __ ] oh well you know i i eat the
shittiest meat too like i'll eat hot
dogs i don't give a [ __ ] i don't give a
kid i'll walk down some [ __ ] hot dogs
hell yeah salami [ __ ] pepperoni i
don't give a [ __ ] beef jerky you [ __ ]
a right i'm gonna eat that [ __ ] so why
they think people on the left only eat
vegetables i mean i i don't get it but
let's listen to also what they think
what what kennedy thinks they do they
almost always enter a swimming pool by
the stairs
they also don't believe in free speech
almost always enter the pool by the
stairs that's right that's right i don't
i have no i actually like i don't know
if he like improv that or he thought
that he's like okay let's see what is
more woke than anything ever
it's probably walking down the stairs
into the pool as opposed to doing a
cannonball
i just thought that was an old person
thing you know i thought that was
generational right well right right i i
don't or someone who doesn't want their
swimming suit to come off because they
dive in the pool i i don't understand i
don't ever dive in but i will tell you
in my old age like i used to do the
polar airplane [ __ ] no matter and and
i'm back in oregon there's no humidity
in the air here right so it can get very
cold even in the summer to swim and i
used to go full balls to the wall jump
in
total shock to the system and now i'm
old and i have to like i have to ease
into that [ __ ] dude
i think it has to do with being broke
right that's right that's right you know
what
i i don't mean to act like that kennedy
is somehow this clip of him and somehow
you know we should be reacting to it
politically but really it does show you
how the establishment because kennedy at
one time i mean and he still could be
called the establishment i'm i'm sure
the cue anonymous would be like oh he
kennedy he he's not he's he's jfk
junior's cousin or something and yeah
carlson is doing right he's framing
kevin mccarthy as a liberal right right
he's like we can't let kevin mccarthy
take over the speakership because we'll
have a republican-controlled congress
led by two liberals right right mccarthy
and mcconnell
and that's and that's what kennedy's
doing here essentially is he's trying to
placate to this that's why he's framing
the left as wokers and this swimming
pool vegetables thing i don't understand
it but here's here's the thing here's
the thing is that this is very
significant in in the kevin mccarthy
what you just brought up and even
kennedy doing this weird thing where
he's talking about swimming bulls and
walking in down the stairs and eating
vegetables they're terrified of killer
tomatoes but here's the thing is that
they really are they really are framing
up the 2020 midterm because they're
watching all these trump candidates
because these primaries are coming right
rachel and we're going to see if the
trump candidates are actually going to
win it or not um
yeah oh they will they will and steve
bannon was freaking out i think i
believe it was yesterday i posted a clip
of steve bannon freaking out on his
trader tv cable news channel whatever
the [ __ ] it is um he actually he's
freaking out because purdue is 27 points
behind in a poll in georgia and that's
the trump endorsed candidate um and and
so there's a little bit of a freak out
especially with georgia because they see
that as a strike there not just for the
governor because they can get rid of
kemp and say yeah trump won but they can
also steal that seat back away from uh
warnock um because he's in a special he
was in a special election in the runoff
as we know and now he has to run for the
actual seat yeah this is going to be a
brutal cycle in georgia but he does have
they have the best two campaigns uh the
abrams campaign right not campaign in
georgia and then the beto campaign in
texas in terms of modernized strategy
and messaging okay
and had they not run that stuff in uh
2021 in the special in the general to
get there they would not have made it
where they made it and it did take a
perfect storm of some decreased turnout
in north georgia from republican voters
but ultimately at the end of the day i
mean they turned out like the turnout
raids that the abrams operation got in
that state was just really amazing but
even with all of that in their favor and
because republicans control the voting
process and restricted access it is
going to be a tremendous lift to hold on
to those seats
well and and i think that's a good point
because we can't we can't just look at
this poll in in georgia and see that the
trump candidate is behind kemp because
that's really what is happening is that
the trump candidate purdue who was the
senator who lost is running for governor
in the primary against the current
incumbent governor
kemp and if it wasn't open tony let me
tell you if it was an open race and so
like really to me the trump candidate
comparison to watch is not
um purdue getting his ass handed to him
right in georgia where he's trying to
take on the governor they brought to to
to to brought in so the kemp that
recorded the phone call a 90-minute
criminal conspiracy with donald trump
has been um you know he's been properly
brought back into line
he's never going to be purdue
right produce literally running on a lie
about election fraud it's as fascist as
you could possibly position yourself in
terms of 2020 messaging
but he's up against this this fact that
that the kemp machine there's i mean
there's just a very tight republican
party lock on that kemp machine is very
powerful
but where we really need to look is ohio
because what you're going to see is jd
vance and jd vance is the trump pick
he's being financed by one of his
friends peter thiel who by the way is
has done much more to put us where we
are than the koch brothers and they have
done a [ __ ] talk okay so you should
really google up you know peter thiel
t-h-i-e-l if you have never read about
him oh i've heard about him
but with vance i mean vance is on audio
on this radio interview and he's he says
flat out we're going to dismantle the
left's institutions we're going to get
all purge out all the civil servants so
a civil servant for folks who don't
understand that a bureaucrat they're
they're they are hired on merit and
skill now they used to be it used to be
a patronage system where if you were
friendly with the party in power you got
the position you may not be good for it
but you got it right like trump trump
promoting right and uh but our civil
servants is not just not political it is
isolated intentionally firm politics
vance says on this radio show we're
going to wipe them all out and replace
them with quote our people
and then when the federal courts tell us
we can't do it we're going to thumb our
nose at the courts and say send in your
court army which is a quote to andrew
jackson right and it is also a threat to
completely pull the rug out from our
entire constitutional order to be clear
and that is going to be our senate front
runner in ohio and because of the nature
of ohio its d alignment it's um you know
a very high likelihood that he'll be
elected
you know that that race is a is a very
interesting relation some of these
debates that have been happening because
i'm glad you brought up some of these
other races because if you look to the
pennsylvania race where dr [ __ ]
excuse me dr oz is running um it really
like they just i mean they can't say the
word trump enough like it is really
gross and sick
that they they just they just can't help
but they really do believe that he's
gonna deliver them this victory um even
though eight million more people voted
against him um in the last election but
they still believe that so tell me tell
me about some of these other debates
that you've seen
and how do you feel about the midterm at
this point i know we've talked about it
before and the generic ballot being so
important do you think that these
candidates that you've seen in these
debates now that we've kind of seen them
go back and forth in their primary
debates with the republicans do you
think that those candidates are going to
be able to talk to that generic ballot
or do you think democrats are going to
be able to coalesce a message to make
sure that the
generic ballot hears the democratic
message over the highly amplified trump
message that's right i mean as as of
today tony i can tell you that that is
not what's gonna happen um you know the
strategy that's been put forward by the
party is to micromessage each of these
races uh try to put them into a
localized chamber this is not a new
strategy it's the same strategy just
packaged differently and i guess they
feel like it's novel it's the same one
that lost us 2010 and 2014
huge wave elections
and so that generic ballot that i keep
talking about has not moved since it
crashed you know it um flipped over to
favor republicans i think at the end of
2021 and has stayed there ever since and
in is in fact not changed even after we
moved out of that two-month three-month
nightmare legislative you know in party
fighting mansion cinema news cycle and
moved into ukraine and all of the things
that have come since
all of the good um you know things that
have happened in addition to you know
ongoing turbos obviously none of that
has moved it right because what it will
take to move the generic ballot is as
you just pointed out a concerted
concentrated intentional strategy that
is geared at winning the top line public
debate
so let me ask you what what it what what
can what can people do out there to make
sure that that messaging is there um
obviously there might not be a heavy
lifting done by the institutions
in in the democratic party the only
pro-democracy party that we have in this
country right now and they don't see the
risk maybe what what can be done by just
average people who definitely do not
want to see their democracy destroyed i
mean what can they do what do they say
to people in their community what is the
message what are two or three sentences
two or three questions that they can ask
someone they know to start that
conversation because we may have to do
this ourselves rachel yeah i mean
honestly and like if you've got friends
on the left i mean those are probably
the easiest and most important people
for you to hit because what you're going
to see when you talk to them is oh i'm
mad because i didn't you know they
didn't do anything
right that's van jones that's van jones
this morning by the way i don't know i'm
sure yeah yeah and so like your job is
to re help them redirect their anger
where it belongs okay and that it does
not belong on the democratic party it
belongs on the republican party because
as long as the republican party has
a stranglehold on the senate pretty much
from the filibuster
we will not pass they will not pass any
[ __ ] thing it doesn't matter what you
want
it doesn't matter who's the president
you can put bernie sanders in there and
you're still not getting anything beyond
executive [ __ ] orders out of this
congress in fact you might have gotten
less right so at the end of the day when
people if people are pissed off about
where they stand today they need to be
told number one
this is why we didn't get [ __ ] done and
it wasn't joe manchin okay joe manchin's
responding what's he responding to to a
republican electorate so our problem is
we've got to get our ire
properly focused and van jones and
others like him do nothing to do that
all they do is whine and [ __ ] about our
own party and they just give republicans
a pass like oh well because these people
are obstructionist and not no longer
interested in governing then we're just
going to assume everyone understands
that premise and then starts the
discussion without including them and
it's just so damaging because the people
the audiences that are influenced by
that commentary don't have the same
education and context of government and
how it works as a van jones or rachel
bittikoffer does so when i hear that i
know what they mean but a lot of the
audience doesn't and so when they hear
the stuff what they what when you ask
them what's the problem they're like
well i guess it must be the democrats
democrats are the problem it's a matter
of will right right well this is always
this is always with the will
right well this is always what the
republicans have been really good at is
making an enemy and we we have always we
have always made ourselves the enemy
just like van jones is doing this
morning or our last night whenever the
hell the clip was i don't know when the
hell he said this he's basically saying
that joe biden and the democrats have
done nothing and it was all the like
like voting rights and everything else
shut the [ __ ] up the house pass voting
rights there is 50 50 republicans and
not a damn one of them in the house who
voted for voting rights it's not the
democrats who didn't vote for democrat
for voting rights that's all [ __ ]
and van jones needs to you know shut his
trap but he's got the he's got the right
to speak but here's what we also have
the right to do is to call him out on
his [ __ ] and to call everyone else
on their [ __ ] and amp well let him
just get them to understand like what
you are doing when you do this
is suppressing our own vote and the
really [ __ ] up part tony is the entire
reason the republican party created the
obstruction strategy which they did in
that restaurant back in 2009 on the eve
of the inaugural is for this so that
they could deny
democratic office holders any [ __ ]
victory to take home and run on so you
are literally doing the gop's bidding if
you sit at elections because you feel
like democrats aren't deliberate
right right well because again i go back
to there is only one party in this
country that is interested in democracy
and we've seen this this week with the
tapes of kevin mccarthy being such a
[ __ ] coward i mean here is a guy
who's supposed to be their leader he's
supposed to be the one in charge and
he's he not only not only did he not
stand up for his convictions that he had
in those calls but then then when he
gets called out on on the phone calls
and the [ __ ] he said bad about donald
trump he says no that's a [ __ ] lie i
didn't say any of that [ __ ] the tapes
get released and he looks like a [ __ ]
coward and it's drip drip drip drip drip
and it's obvious it's obvious now why
some of these republicans the few liz
cheney and some others
said you know what i know these phone
calls were [ __ ] recorded i know
they're gonna have us on tape and kevin
mccarthy didn't give a [ __ ] because he
doesn't care about democracy
he doesn't really care about his
constituents he doesn't care about
policy he only gives a [ __ ] about one
thing and one thing only and that's
remaining in power that is
because we seen soon after these calls
were recorded and we we listened to
these calls all week um after he was you
know saying he was gonna get which is
all [ __ ] he was just
pandering to the people that were on the
phone call as far as i could tell i
really thought he was gonna go tell
trump to resign give me a break kevin
mccarthy he
soon after that he got on a plane went
to mar-a-lago put his cheeto dust knee
pads on and was kissing the ring and
changing diapers i mean this is [ __ ]
ridiculous that kevin mccarthy was gonna
be a tough guy it's it's absolutely
bonkers to me that that is their leader
and and we with all this with all this
election
that the stuff that we have to run on
they're setting the ball up on the t for
us all we have to do is get a national
message out there and continue to pound
that message and continue to make an
enemy
for democracy because they truly are
they're trying to commit a coup as we
speak in arizona we see we see people
like carrie lake running for governor
who want to who want to overturn the
last election and we're almost we're
closer to the next one than we are from
the last one and she wants to overturn
that one still i mean these people are
out of their minds they're not for
democracy they're not for a republic
they're not their their fascist is what
they are and their leader is some weak
coward kevin mccarthy who's willing to
stand aside for his own for his own
power and let them take over and do
whatever they want and run rough shot
over the people and democracy and
they're getting a big as this fire media
who continues to treat things like you
know these purdue comments in the debate
they're so disturbing they're absolutely
disqualified no americans should be able
to be on any ballot anywhere for any
elected office with those kinds of
public views and yet our media never
wants to talk about hey the republican
party is running people who should not
be
packed because they're advocating openly
for insurrection or
you know um the coup conspiracy that was
executed by their party right i mean
this it's so [ __ ] weird to me
even though i've really spent a lot of
time now digging into these other
societies that have crumbled
it's just so weird to me that the media
is dead silent on the abnormality of
this republican party and that i'm the
one that has to come and remind people
this party went through an internal
civil war that started in 2010
escalated in 2014 when cantor got
bounced and they decided to disavow the
republican big ten autistic autopsy
report that the party had put together
after 2013 and when you see the divide
for the never trumpers who left the
party that was the autopsy team they're
like hey we can't win national elections
if we're a bunch of racist [ __ ] so
let's try to moderate ourselves on on
immigration and a few other things and
not go native this because that's going
to give us that's going to make our
electorate white problem even worse and
they lost they they had a chance to win
that debate until cantor got tossed
and then they lost and with trump coming
down that golden escalator
in may of 2015 and them not rejecting
him him rising through the ranks paul
ryan normalizing him after he secured
the nomination that they put the cap on
the old republican party and and sealed
it away
and this thing that we're fighting now
is a different beast and the media just
never wants to give that context it's
very dis doesn't hurt disheartening
well you know they are in the trump loop
and the other thing that they do is this
bullside [ __ ] like oh both sides both
sides are you know look what how bad the
democrats are doing and but but you know
republicans you know they're still you
know and they normalize it like you're
saying right like they and and the other
problem that we have is that people so
many people in this country pay
attention to right wing media and i
think one of the reasons why is because
you know everyone says all the
mainstream media is left-wing and that's
all [ __ ] there isn't a left-wing
media apparatus like there is no big
huge
huge apparatus that is left-wing media
that can push a left-wing a true
left-wing message that says [ __ ] you to
fascism yeah when when when you have cnn
like nodding their head as van jones is
basically
get serving up on a platter what the far
right wants which is van jones a black
guy who was in who was in the obama
administration basically parroting their
points on cnn say say hey look hey look
libtards hey look you [ __ ] libs here's
here's a guy on cnn he's an obama guy on
cnn giving you how bad oh how bad bom uh
biden sucks and and
it just it just is infuriating
that everyone thinks that's what we need
to consider tony that he actually wasn't
in the obama administration because he
couldn't get confirmed
right right or having the balls to say
hey climate change is real okay that's
what dan jones does well that's the far
left now that's the far left the part
the far right wants fascism the far left
the radical socialists
want to talk about climate change want
to talk about not going broke over a
medical bill they want their kids to
start school at three instead of five
they they want to make sure they're not
[ __ ] broke their entire lives because
they go to college to make sure that
they're economically sound in their
career so these are the things that are
supposed to be radical and extreme not
marrying children in tennessee not not
basically taxing floridians to get rid
of a private industry which is their
biggest tourist industry which is disney
because disney somehow woke because they
support equity and equality for human
beings this is really
and and
you're telling me
making sure that college is affordable
and people start their education at
three instead of five and making sure
people don't go br broke because of a of
a medical bill that's extreme this is
really what they are giving us
everything we need to message yeah well
i mean keep in mind how do you define
liber i think i just tweeted about this
before the show i said you know today a
liberal is defined by somebody who
trusts science reads actual news and
watches actual news and believes in
diversity and equality all right i mean
if that makes me [ __ ] how
very clear that there's one party
that lives in reality land and reads
information
you know and there's another one that's
completely [ __ ] looney tunes right
and and that looney tunes is not
something that's a punch line or like a
abstract the way the clinton team tried
to focus on trump
that looney tunes is gonna be in charge
of you
right
well and that's and that goes back to
the clip i played in the beginning is is
kennedy because he's playing to the
[ __ ] looney tunes and he truly
believes that these people he believes
that these people listening fox news are
stupid enough to believe that people who
walk down the stairs into the pool are
somehow part of the disney woke crowd i
mean ron desantis was on stage talking
about how disney was
creating cartoon porn or some [ __ ] and
sexualizing cartoons i'm like what the
[ __ ] are you dude number one it it you
people do not have disney plus you're
not watching in kanto and and by the way
you're not watching all the cartoons
that walt disney made that sexualized uh
cartoons and women give me a break
looney tunes disney have always
sexualized women have always sexualized
cartoons you people you people are the
ones who are sexualizing kids gender how
many of them took their kids to go see
who framed roger rabbit right
[Music]
you know right right jessica rabbits
their first group of children was back
in the 90s and now they've all divorced
their old hags and married their
mistresses you know their
seventeen-year-old child brides and had
all right
i mean they are they are the new
republican kidnappers i mean they really
are they jody before i jump off i got a
very important question for you yes
all right let's say i walk into the pool
using the stairs but
i'm eating a slice of pepperoni pizza
am i still well [ __ ]
don't do not i i can't even i can't even
begin to describe you how if we pose
this question to the fastest republicans
how their heads
you know what you should do you should
go go tweet that and tag kennedy
this is something that we gotta do
i know well these are important matters
rachel thank you for joining us now
everyone stick around right after this
break uh gabe sanchez is going to join
us and we're going to do bonehead of the
week so not this rachel thanks for
joining us we appreciate having you
every single time
see you next time thank you very much
rachel we'll talk to you soon
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day i'm
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back we always
enjoy having dr rachel's bitte copper
you should need her advice on this
election
[Music]
she definitely knows what she's talking
about when it comes to messaging
politics elections
and how to get into government so you
can govern
speaking of people being in government
uh gabe i have a clip i want to show you
welcome
hey first off i want to say happy
birthday to robin oh yes happy birthday
to robin happy birthday
to
[Music]
because me and rachel talked about this
in the last segment when she was on um
it's ron desantis talking about he i
don't know if he i don't know what he's
really talking about here he's talking
about like cartoon porn or something
i don't know
intuit into it
you're in the cartoon porn or he's in
the car dude i'm a sexual deviant
here's what i tweeted i said nazi ron
wants to take away cartoon porn what
will josh hawley do on the internet now
i don't i mean i'm not i'm not really
sure what josh holly would do on the
internet if there was no cartoon i am so
interested and confused i'll take some
time i've not seen this clip so i don't
know what's going on let's listen he is
in front of like whiskey barrel it's
kind of weird i don't know what the [ __ ]
this is let's just watch
one of the things that really
bugged me were these zoom videos with
all these people that are high up in
disney
talking about how it was their intention
to inject sexuality into the programming
for these very young people that's
that's not what they they said on and
zoom calls and this guy is he i i'm i'm
i'm confused is he saying he got copies
of these or he was like creeping in on
their zoom goal yeah was he like zoom
bombing i don't know
did was he actually having a call with
disney or was it with like tuban i'm not
sure well he might have been he might
have been lubin and tubin
zuman lubin and tubin listen what he
says about cartoon porn and so my wife
and i
you know we're thinking to ourselves you
know when we were young you could watch
cartoons
without having to worry now parents have
to sit there and worry about what are
they trying to inject in what type of
idea
is this like bleach or is this something
completely different but is he okay so i
i mean what i will say is that cartoons
in the past were not great like you look
back and you're like oh that's actually
pretty cool
right yeah like you're like oh that's
just that's that's
rapey that's right really really assault
yeah or like oh they're doing they're
doing blackface in that cartoon huh
right and it's like oh wait
well i mean what you see back then you
didn't have to parents didn't have to
worry i guess because you know what it
aligned exactly with what they wanted to
see that's right that's right but let's
let's the fascists you mean yeah yeah
where women are sexualized and you know
treated as the objects that's what
you're saying right
to have cartoons that don't you know
don't uh treat women as just objects and
that's the republican humanizes them
yeah they cannot have that they can't
have
cartoons they're [ __ ] splooge like oh
this is exactly what i wanted you know
or it's like sexual assault and and
other sort of crazy insane bigoted
behavior right they definitely
definitely don't want women to be
humanized it's not something yeah not at
all biology are they trying to pursue
and that is wrong
what kind of ideology are they trying to
pursue as if as if like cartoons like
the whole goal of cartoons because
that's truly what he's saying is we want
our cartoons to push our ideology is
what he's saying it's again it's this
[ __ ] republican projection [ __ ] where
he's saying we want we want our cartoons
to push our agenda and that's what we
have to push um and and it's not the
wokers have you seen this video the
woken video what
this sounds like a cartoon the wokers
well
he i might have to make a pilot together
he is he is kind of a cartoon here this
is uh senator kennedy you know someone
called him in the comments earlier i
think they called him
uh foghorn [ __ ] i think is what they
call it so he's kind of cartoonish here
but i didn't play the whole clip of the
rachel but we'll play it here
um i actually maybe we did play real
quick but let's play it again so gabe
can hear and we'll get gage reaction on
kennedy's
um
framing up of woke wokers
wokers
i'm serious
twit twitter is run
by wokers wokers represent the crank
wing of the democratic party
uh wokers as i've said before easy to
recognize most of them eat food
only fit for rabbits
so
and so first off first off
twitter is run by a bunch of crank
lefties who are known as wokers and
their the idea of the wokeness is to
sell it to a [ __ ] like elon musk
that's the woke
this literally makes no [ __ ] sense at
all what he's trying to say because in
the context that he's saying in here is
that and let me bring it back up here
free speech principles left-wing
censorship a threatened left-wing
censorship agenda so he's saying it in
the context that elon musk is going to
save free speech and save americans from
all those big tech billionaires those
wokers who are out there who like to eat
vegetables apparently they're terrified
of vegetables listen man you can't eat
veggies the only veggies you can eat is
a as a tomato in a in a little leaf of
lettuce if you're having a burger
because oh damn that's a miracle
that's the only way you can have garden
that's the only way you can have garden
yeah and that's you know you won't you
know you we don't want any anyone
rummaging through a little rabbit garden
no no
okay
this is [ __ ] crazy you talk about
cartoonish here's kennedy listen listen
to what else he says apparently
apparently you know if you swim in a
pool there's a certain way that wokers
get in a pool i'm not [ __ ] you they
almost always enter a swimming pool by
the stairs
this is woke-ism gabe this is pure
woke-ism 101
you have to you can't you are not
allowed to do a cannonball you are not
allowed to go off the diving board okay
this guy okay kennedy over here i
guarantee
150
that this [ __ ] takes the stairs
into the pool because he's a prime
example of oh no i've fallen and i can't
get up emergency alert i guarantee if he
were to go into a pool he would just
jump in he wouldn't just like i mean who
knows maybe he just like slithered his
way on in off off the edge but what i do
think he does is he takes the goddamn
stairs he takes the goddamn stairs like
a goddamn woker
because he's a woker [ __ ] kennedy is
such a [ __ ] woker listen listen to
what else he says this is brilliant at
the end here gabe it's brilliant if
you're talking about a cartoon character
they also don't believe in free speech
i do
which means i respect the right of the
wokers to have their opinion
so so not only not on not only is he is
he saying that
somehow
again i don't i don't know how the logic
computes here that a bunch of left-wing
radical woker socialist cranks are going
to sell twitter which is some kind of
left-wing thing that's suppressing
right-wing speech there right and doing
a successful job at it like literally if
your narrative is correct
kennedy
if your [ __ ] narrative is correct
that twitter is run by a bunch of
left-wing cranks that is suppressing the
right-wing speech and that's their goal
why in the actual [ __ ] would they sell
it to a [ __ ] who is going to allow
right-wingers to spew their racism their
bigotry right their hatred their threats
on that platform
why would they sell it to him when he's
when he's basically saying that's what
he's going to do
right that's not free speech your free
speech does not extend to twitter you
dumb [ __ ] i think there's a lot
yeah there there's a lot that goes on
here with this whole narrative of like
uh the left controls twitter and it's
anti-free speech which you could say is
probably more one of or one of the more
um
platf or one of the more free speech
platforms that's out there actually
um but what do you mean by what do you
mean by that because that that is
important
yeah so so what i'm saying i mean like
you know most platforms
assuming you don't break the terms of
service that you when you check the
little box when you create your account
it says hey if you want to
uh contribute to this community of
people whether it's like share
retweet quote tweet comment
whatever the action might be
you can say whatever you want however
if you break one of these rules like
you're harassing someone you're
revealing private information
uh you're sharing um
very
vile uh photos and death threats you're
doing anything like that where it's like
hey any normal person because here's the
thing
let's assume that twitter isn't this
online platform let's just assume
twitter is real life okay and you wanted
to express these same things now you
could take an action but there's going
to be a consequence if you wanted to
take photos or share photos and post
them around
of of of
i don't know crazy insane disgusting
gross vile things something's going to
happen to you right you might be uh
stopped by someone a citizen or you
might be stopped by authorities i have
no idea but what i can say is like you
could say whatever you want you could do
whatever you want but however just like
there's a terms of service there are
rules and laws in society
that will cause
a consequence for the action you decided
to do wait you're saying you're saying
the freedom of speech doesn't actually
mean they get to say whatever they want
without consequence because this sounds
like something i've been saying for a
long time where let's take let's take
walmart for example because uh these
free speech idiots love walmart oh yeah
you might hate you may hate walmart
right you may hate walmart and you can
speak out against walmart but you can't
go on walmart's property and paint on
the side of their store [ __ ] walmart i
mean you can yeah you can do that but
you'll have consequences now what you
can do
what you can do still with not without
consequences is you can go stand on the
public sidewalk that is off of walmart's
property and hold a sign that says
[ __ ] walmart right exactly you might
have consequences for that too but that
is your free speech your free speech
does not allow you to enter on walmart's
property right on the side of the
building and paint on it [ __ ]
walmart you just don't have that's not a
free i mean you may think it's speech
and it may be speech but i mean it's
you might think it's speech or free
speech because you were able you had the
the right to do it
right but that doesn't that doesn't stop
like a police officer from arresting you
that doesn't stop walmart from suing you
for vandalism right or exactly
prosecuting you or putting i mean you
might even end up in jail depending on
the price that it takes to take your
vandalism exactly right and so when you
look at when you look at twitter it's
the same thing you check that that
little check box right there when you
sign up an account and says i agreed as
a privacy policy in the terms of service
which nobody reads right so when they
get in trouble
my free speech it's like no it's
literally
the their legal team
made a document that says all of these
things that you have to abide by if you
break the rules that you agree to then
there are consequences like they can
bounce off the property yeah they can
say hey you gotta go if you go in
walmart and you're acting a fool and
acting like a dumb ass inside their
store they can bounce you off their
property now
one step further we seen uh today i
don't know if you've seen this but there
is a new oath keeper who was one of the
eleven that was indicted with stewart
rhodes um he is going to plea in a court
i don't know if this has happened yet or
not but apparently he's going to plead
to seditious conspiracy in a court um
which he's making a plea deal here it
looks like more of these oath keepers
are moving to the side of being uh
actually on the side of the government
here because that's kind of what the
government does and the doj does when
they prosecute you and indict you
they're like are you on the side of the
government are you on the side of the
defense and it looks like they're
walking to the side of the government
here with a plea deal
but the thing is is a lot of those
people that have been
indicted and charged and even convicted
and sitting in prison right now as we
speak
were used
used social media
has he already pled guilty according to
scott mcfarland he says you know
happening now this was uh 9 36 am my
time oh okay okay 20 23 minutes ago
gotcha so since we've been on the show
yeah plea hearing in a very high level
us case with oathkeeper case brian
ulrich now he showed some photos of
where he was and then it said pleading
guilty
to seditious conspiracy and obstruction
of official proceeding
uh he's not the first zookeeper to plead
guilty to seditious conspiracy there is
also joshua james of right arab alabama
who did that is the one that is the one
who is who was protecting roger stone on
the day of january 6th he was the one
standing next to roger stone the entire
time that joshua now allegedly also
according to these uh the transcript
ulric allegedly sent this text message
on uh december 31st 2020 seven days
before the capital attack it says uh all
work sent to leadership signal chat
relating to firearms quote unquote uh
someone can tell me if i'm crazy but i'm
planning on having a backpack for
regular use and then a separate backpack
with my ammo loadout with some basics
that i can just switch to
if uh [ __ ] truly if [ __ ] truly
oh i think what he meant to say was like
if [ __ ] hits the fan right he also added
uh though he didn't say it correctly uh
he also added i will be the guy running
around with the budget ar
so here's the thing so that text message
because you have the freedom in this
country to text whatever number you want
but that doesn't mean that that text
message isn't illegal it doesn't mean
that you're not committing a crime doing
it even though you're think you're
practicing your freedom of speech you're
practicing speech but you do not have
the freedom to commit crimes with your
speech you do not now speaking of that i
have a great graphic um that i want to
show that tom powell jr put on instagram
and maybe this clears to that forever
button
um this image never gets old like you
can use it for so many things on the
republican party or just bros you know
why i mean this guy looks like maybe an
oath keeper maybe one of these freedom
of speech guys or these listen you don't
understand right right you don't
understand as he's holding a beard
thinking he's tough and the quote here
is i'm telling you elon is gonna save
free speech and protect us from big tech
billionaires it's perfect it describes
these elon stands that we've been seeing
in our comments for [ __ ] days because
we keep saying elon's not gonna buy this
and gabe it sounds like you may have
more evidence of this um today right
maybe okay yeah and we're gonna talk
about it because elon musk showed up in
the uh bonehead of the week um which
we're going to do bonehead of the week
here in just a few minutes um
one one more thing before yeah and i
have something to add on this uh on this
guess too go ahead that's uh yeah yeah
so it says he seems to be having a
moment judge indicates ulrich seems to
be struggling to ask if he can have a
moment of time he responds i'm trembling
in a trembling voice uh i'm not gonna
it's not gonna get any easier
uh and so right now the sentencing
guidelines this is as of 10 minutes ago
are roughly five to seven years in
prison and a 25 000 fine the judge is
explaining that all work has agreed to
cooperate with the feds and he's
struggling and overcome by tears in
court hearing for a second time judges
asked him do you need a moment a little
cry baby well let me tell you something
let me tell you something the reason why
this guy is so [ __ ] nervous gabe is
because he's sitting in front of a judge
and he's basically handing his freedom
away that he's that because he's not a
speech because of the speech he was he
was using the freedom of speech that the
entitlement that he had that he thought
he had he is giving his freedom away
because of the consequences of that and
let me tell you something the other
thing that he's doing is the reason why
he's completely terrified is because he
knows what he's gonna have to tell the
government because making this deal with
the government and the doj this guy
doesn't get to suppress his speech
anymore he has to tell them because if
he does not tell them the truth and the
whole truth anytime they ask him when
they ask him this deal is null and void
yeah and that guy will go right back to
being to being tried and the other thing
too is the government doesn't get to use
that evidence that he's given against
him but it gives them a road map of how
to find it and that is the key here that
is the key with this deal and and folks
out there who don't think that justice
is going to be brought to these [ __ ]
this is a
just another example of why people out
there saying that the doj and merrick
garland are not doing their job are
[ __ ] wrong you're [ __ ] wrong if
you think they're not it might not be
happening as fast as you want but it is
happening as fast as justice needs to
happen yeah i mean yes we want this to
happen before 2022 midterms but that but
we cannot sacrifice an actual conviction
and prosecutions and put the people who
deserve to be behind bars rather be oath
keepers proud boys roger stone steve
bannon or donald trump himself right if
they need to be behind bars we need to
do our due diligence to do that
and if the doj needs time to build these
cases because let me tell you something
this prob or this oath keeper uh
pleading guilty to seditious conspiracy
is one more step
up the ladder and that is the most
important thing because let me tell you
something if this guy has something on
stuart rhodes then that might be the
next that might be the next rung of the
ladder because stewart rhodes knows a
lot about who he was supposed to be
reporting to and he was supposed to be
giving him the order of martial law and
we know that
speaking of martial law
we have someone who
thinks they know what martial law is
maybe maybe or maybe not she ended up on
bone end of the week should we should we
go to bonehead of the week and
and and break down the people's vote
here on these models but yes okay let's
see the people here that's what people
are waiting for we're here for yeah what
they want
there's a lot of marge tape to go
through oh yeah
there's some new tape that even came out
yesterday that she published that does
not make her look that's better maybe
we'll start there so stick around right
after this break we're gonna go to
bonehead of the week do not do not go
anywhere you are not going to want to
miss this this edition
of bonehead of the week we'll be right
back
[Music]
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopers mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your drew today drew feed the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels we're back to the king of
brilliant this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
oh boy it's been a week
with the elon musk pretending to buy
twitter
marjorie perjury green
and we have a lauren laura ingraham
video and we also have some alpha cucks
and some dishonorable mentions for you
welcome to bone hint of the week look at
this look at here you got you got some
new graphics and everything new
new graphics
do we have to have everything in for the
show are we gonna put them i i put them
in the folder for you to have
right now i'm not going to call somebody
out for not doing their yeah
oopsie
well you know
all right i'll load him in right now
sometimes it happens sometimes build up
the anticipation here
you know uh bone end of the week for
everyone who doesn't know we put out a
poll every every single week where you
guys go get to vote for bonehead of the
week it's on at tony michael's pod our
podcast twitter page go take the vote
there and then what we do every single
friday
every single friday in the second hour
we break down your vote for bonehead of
the week
and we have we have of course a a
regular here this week um how many times
has she won do you i don't know you know
i tried to here's the thing i tried to
search this i think i had to go back
through like my actual files because i
tried to look it up on twitter and it
only says like four or five times i
don't think that's right at all but
right what she the only time i think
she's actually lost when she was in a
poll
i believe that it was the only time
she's lost when she was in a pool was
during uh bonehead madness i believe
that
yeah that's the one where i mean listen
i was like i will rename uh bonehead
madness to marge madness
and unfortunately she didn't win but
well it it happens it happens sometimes
like that well let's go to the song to
the bone of the week and let's start
this week's edition of bonehead of the
week
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome
to
this edition of bone end of the week
where we break down your vote
for bonehead of the week we have some
great contenders this week yeah i mean
fantastic boneheads oh baby you don't
you don't hardly get more boneheaded
than these boneheads oh man of course
i know you got some new news on elon
musk that we'll get to um we have
marjorie taylor green marjorie perjury
green and then uh
the fox news's local nazi uh laura
ingraham i'm not making that up when i
say nazi like everyone's not going to
come out i'm like no i'm serious her
brother brother's brother said she's a
monster
right well i mean they they had they had
mine comp right there on the coffee
table yeah right i mean that's that's
the thing that's the thing um you know
she's throwing her waves out in a very
specific
uh form or or way you know like uh
so let's let's get to laura let's get
the laura ingraham um
stuff out of the way here real quick
because i want to i think i've got a
clip of it but the gist of it is why
we're talking about her she
she actually said that she kept her
mother
working until she was 75 to pay off her
student loan debt yeah seven
73 to pay off the loan debt she
basically was like this my mother had to
pay off the loan debts until she was 73.
now that logic basically says well
my mother had to do it or i had to do it
uh everyone else should have to the
problem with that is that as a society
right as a group of people that want to
better the next generation right because
republicans are always like oh
the uh the the budget is too high it's
going to cause a bunch of financial
issues for the the next generation the
next generation we got to save our
children we got to do this right
but
like republicans they're complete
hypocrites because what ends up
happening is they say oh no no i had to
pay for my way through college which by
the way for a lot of these boomers and
older people
it was very
uh affordable okay
and the other side of it is that when
they say oh you have to pay
they feel like oh well i had to do the
work you should also do the work right i
shouldn't make it easier for you i
should make uh getting education
affordable i shouldn't making uh or i i
shouldn't give you the ability to to
better prepare yourself for the
workforce to get a good job to get a
higher salary instead you should go into
debt crippling debt with with the
interest rates and in tuition that rise
higher than inflation right so you look
at this and they just say well
i did it so you should too which is i
think a most uh idiotic way to think
about this because at the end of the day
we should be thinking about how to
better everyone that comes after us
right we want to leave a place for them
to live to exist and if we continue now
this pattern of like well i did it you
have to there's gonna be nothing left
and no one's gonna be able to follow
follow suit with a proper education or
to get a good uh salary or or what have
you like there's a long list of things
that this like targets right which goes
to getting good housing right and
getting stability in your life these are
all things that republicans uh preach
but don't actually follow
well of course they don't well here's
the clip and um margie margie she wants
me to point out that it's that it's a
hard g
margin only mention that because margie
marge
but margie midas margie thank you for
the super no relation to the other yes
and and by the way gabe everyone's
pointing out that that the youtube
youtube
um you can put a poll up on youtube
everyone i pointed this out to the
executive producer and the team of
executive producers that put together
the bone end of the week poll
and they really they really kind of
flattened me last week on no no no i
didn't flatten you i just said oh you're
making you not you the the production
team you know yeah i've got a group of
interns that do all the work for me
right right all the way
that i pay with nothing because like
republicans i support child labor no i
don't uh but
i it's not that i flattened your idea
what i said was yeah oh you're just
giving me more work to do you're making
my job harder because now i got to go to
the other part
now you have to continue with the chat
now you have to contend with the chat
here yeah
i it's not me and i promise i did not
see this thing i did not see this thing
it's not me i did you put up wait hold
on did you put a pull up on youtube that
i didn't see no no no no no no okay i
mean you go to youtube check it out i i
did not see this thing at all these
people know that there's pulls up we can
do it for next week we can do it for
next we'll do it we'll try it next week
yeah i'll just i'll just tabulate
everything together yeah you'll have to
do math you'll have to do math it'd be
horrible it'd be horrible uh andrea
thank you for the super chat uh thanks
for letting me hang out for lunch when i
can marge
um
martial arts as well oh my gosh thank
you andrew for the super chat let's go
to this video really quick um and let's
listen to what this
[ __ ] bonehead says about her mom
working or i don't know my mom was a
waitress till she was 73 somehow she got
herself to the poll and voted on
election day i mean
you know i don't know this whole thing
of having elections for weeks and months
before the election so this is a little
different video than that her mom works
till she's 73 you know this is she's
talking about how they're still alive i
i don't know i i'm not really
as a millionaire which i'm assuming she
is she was like i mean like i get i get
the whole thing is like if you're
working your whole life and you want to
still have that sense of like
a purpose you want to continue working
right right well a lot of people a lot
of people work in retirement they they
just want something to do they want to
get out of there and if that's the thing
you want to do that's totally fine i
don't know what the situation is but i
also have a feeling like laura ingraham
will just be like oh no i'm not going to
i'm not going to financially assist you
mom because you got to pull yourself
over your bootstraps i'm not going to
give you the money i'm not going to pay
for you to live somewhere you got to do
it yourself so meanwhile her mom's like
[ __ ] my life i got to go do all this
work myself because my goddamn nazi
daughter won't help me out right
well i mean i mean laurie ingraham
probably is strapped for cash i mean she
probably doesn't no i'm just kidding she
she makes all kinds of money propagating
her putin [ __ ] and her nazi propaganda
okay let's let's move on from the the
local nazi at fox news and let's go to
the next bonehead because you have some
news um about elon musk before we get to
the dishonorable mention and the outlook
duck uh i definitely want to make sure
we talk about elon everyone knows uh
we've been dogging on elon for a while
on this show and we actually believe
that he will not buy twitter is right
that's my personal opinion but yeah yeah
what is the new news about elon and him
buying selling tesla that sort of thing
so this was actually something i meant
to uh bring up yesterday which is like
the dip in the stock uh that happened
for tesla right everyone was like well
what's happening who's selling like
there's a massive sell-off are there
investors yes it is is it investors who
don't have confidence in the fact that
this guy said i am 100 committed to
advancing electric vehicle and the
industry uh you know with tesla
and when you see your ceo uh go off and
do some personal you know like you know
a little pet project to go by twitter
and that you know distracts him
from tesla and also there's a lawsuit
that's against tesla uh that's happening
this fall so like that's a pretty big
important thing that needs to kind of
keep focus on but
um i'll talk about that in a sec um
but for for investors they're like well
if elon's distracted then he can't focus
on advancing the company and making me
money right and that's what the issue is
here so then on on tuesday everyone's
like whoa dude stock goes down right and
they're up again there is uh investor
kind of people clamoring to be like i'm
out i'm out i don't trust this anymore
this is bad news you know also driving
down the stock to say like if the value
of the stock you know dollar per share
or per per share um
ends up being sure
lower than what was agreed upon by the
financial institutions and elon to
leverage and then the deal right in the
right right right right right
because the deal says like basically
again i don't know what the actual
number is i think it's like sub 750 is
when
the deal goes belly up to say like you
actually can't leverage against this
company because the equity that you're
you're actually proposing is less than
what you agreed upon and so if that
happens then the banks
take their commitment because again it's
nothing that's in writing like it's not
a contract that says you have to giving
this money they said if you can
uh satisfy this financially here and and
commit to this then we will also commit
to giving you this money well i think
this is all bad news for this deal and
it is more indication that this thing's
going to go way south um number one
there was talk yesterday about 4 billion
but you're gonna you're going to tell us
that it's almost 9 billion of tesla
stock that elon sold is that right
exactly so what ended up happening was
yeah so when you as you know an investor
or as a ceo right you've got you've got
shares you sell those you have a day or
two
of buffer
to announce it right so he sells he
sells about four billion
on tuesday
and then two days later he has to report
what those why does he have to report
because he's the ceo
uh
well i mean that's one of the main
things for sure because you want to know
off a bunch of stock and you'd be like
what the hell is going on does he have
information that we need to know and
that's what i was really trying to make
the point yesterday is that if elon musk
was really serious about buying twitter
which he's not he's not serious because
if he was truly serious he would take 18
to 24 months to put himself in a
position to where he could buy twitter
and twitter would probably be okay with
that like if he's gonna give him 45
billion or he actually was serious about
it and he wanted to buy twitter and all
this [ __ ] he would have he would have
put himself in a position where he
wasn't the tesla ceo he could have sold
off the stock over a period of time that
would not have uh negatively affected
tesla and pissed off the investors there
he would have done these things if he
was actually serious or if he's not a
[ __ ]
bonehead now
i believe this is the problem that he's
gonna have
he is selling off a stock in a company
that he is the ceo he's pissing off the
investors but also what he's doing is
he's selling a very prop what was a
profitable stock before he started this
nonsense
for a for a company that's not
profitable and also this morning we're
hearing that there's no way that
twitter's profits are going to be able
to carry this [ __ ] debt which means
he's selling off a [ __ ] stock of a
company that can carry its own debt
right who is servicing its debt who is
able to pay its [ __ ] bills who is it
that is solvent they're in the black and
he's trading away nine billion dollars
and confidence in that company for a
company that may or may not be able to
service the debt that he is going to
take on and here's what i mean by that
twitter is profitable
it is but the problem is is there's not
enough profit to pay the [ __ ] banks
their money so when you go take a loan
the bank doesn't just give it to you for
free it's not like when elon takes
government money uh in subsidies for his
electric cars the government's not going
to give it
gets paid for uh spacex right yeah or or
the the
the satellites that he helped put over
ukraine right he's like i gave it to you
guys like no actually the government
gave you money money
exactly they're not going to subsidize
his twitter deal right exactly so in
the bank is the one that's going to loan
the money so they're a private industry
and in capitalism we all know that
there's a margin and that margin is
profit [ __ ] right and the bank's not
gonna
not gonna do this deal if they do not
think their margin is gonna be kept
there's no [ __ ] way if the bank
thinks he's gonna default on this thing
and if the mac doesn't add up where
number one elon musk there's no
confidence that he can number one run
tesla and make decisions that um on a
public company the bank is not going to
make the bet that elon can make good
decisions on a privately owned company
where he's not held to sec rules and
regulations and he's not held to certain
regulations when you have a publicly
owned company there's no way the bank's
gonna take that deal number one number
two the bank is not gonna put themselves
in a position where their loan cannot be
serviced they're not gonna do it if
anyone out there has went and got a loan
they do a credit check yes it may be
like for a ha but for a mortgage you got
to provide so much more documentation to
make sure that you can service that debt
that is what is happening right now
right now the banks
and all the agents the government
agencies twitter themselves they're
making sure that elon musk can service
this thing and let me tell you something
him selling nine billion dollars worth
of tesla stock
basically overnight and surprising
people with this
is not a good sign that he can service
this so that's the other thing too is
like there's that there's the two-day
you have to report it within two days
right so he sells it on tuesday
yesterday or two days after the fact and
says oh uh elon musk has sold four and a
half roughly four and a half billion
worth of of shares right and people like
oh [ __ ] because one the i think the most
important thing that people need to know
here is
elon has gone on the record multiple
times and said i
as elon musk will be the last person to
pull out money from tesla it's a bad
signal to investors when your ceo who
has in the past said one i will
completely 100 devote myself to tesla
and its operations and two
says i will be the last one to take
money out
and then when you see he goes ah you
know what i'm gonna actually buy this
other company that i want to be the ceo
of and i'm gonna sell shares of this
company to to help fund this purchase
and then on top of that we find out
today that it's not only four and a half
billion or like four billion it ends up
being closer to eight and a half billion
just again yeah because so so he's
doubled
he's double killed his confidence here
like right exactly because again there's
that two-day period where you have to go
from execution of the sale to reporting
of the sale to the sec so what ends up
happening here is you go the 26th to the
28th and then he also sold on the 27th
and he also sold on the 28th and today
new filings come out that show him
selling those things on the 27th and the
28th which gets him to eight and a half
billion and now he's and you know last
night he reported he was like the the
way that he phrased it was somebody
called him out for uh selling the actual
uh tesla shares right for four billion
and he goes as of today there will be or
or rather as of right now there will be
no more selling of tesla after today
right which the way it's raised would
show you that okay
got it okay he's not going to sell past
the 26 but then there's the gap of the
27th and the 28th of april which were uh
thursday and wednesday
and after he's alluded he's alluding to
that but he's not telling people
outright that he sold also
on the 27th and the 28th three days in a
row to get eight and a half billion what
he's gonna do is he's just gonna let
those filings come out publicly because
the sec has to right well and that's
typing that type of lack of transparency
is [ __ ] up one that's what the bank is
going to be terrified of here and also
tesla might punish him if he's not
careful i mean we surmise that there's
no real is there any evidence of that
yet but i mean other than people just
being absolutely pissed and and
so i mentioned earlier there's a lawsuit
that is actually against elon musk when
it comes to tesla so he made an
agreement in 2018 to um
to successfully achieve certain goals at
the company right and he would receive i
think it's 56 billion dollars um
for
for achieving this right it was a 56
billion dollar pay package from tesla
bonus right now here's the problem yeah
now it's 56 with a b billion
billion that's what he was as if
everyone gets a everyone gets a couple
billion dollars in a business if you do
your job right come on man come on no
big deal
so what ends up what ends up happening
here in the situation is there's a
lawsuit that is
against elon musk
because in the first line of the
contract it says you're going to be a
full-time ceo and devote substantially
full-time to the business affairs and
the company you're not going to try to
be some celebrity who does this and does
this and whatever you've agreed in 2018
it was rubber stamped that you're the
ceo and you're committing 100
full-time to this company to make sure
that it achieves its success which means
you have to go all the way to 2028 to
get the full payout of this 10-year
package and what ends up happening is an
investor says well you're not committed
so now there's a lawsuit that is going
to be taken to court in october which is
around the same time that this deal for
twitter is going to at in its in its
shortest time span will be agreed and
and finalized
which
if you compound both these things
together
only helps this lawsuit because what it
shows is that the investor is actually
right in his assumption that he's not
actually committing 100 to tesla he's
not making sure that he's he's committed
all of his
bandwidth resources you know brain power
to making sure that tesla becomes the
number one best
electric vehicle company out there so
that i love how you but i love how you
put brain power in a sentence with elon
musk it really is it really is i mean
all for it you know it's just for those
elon stands out there and those i think
he's a genius right so again this is
what's happening you've got this deal
that's supposed to be finally finalized
by
in the quickest form is done by october
you've also got this lawsuit for a 56
billion dollar uh bonus payout package
for a 10-year contract that says i elon
musk i'm committed to this tesla company
100
and making sure that it is successful
does that mean does that mean like um
you wouldn't buy like a social media
company maybe and be the ceo and solder
i don't know i don't know maxwell thank
you thank you for the super sticker
maxwell and we thank you appreciate it
let's let's move on uh we have some we
have some non-newcomers here for
dishonorable mention alphacut um
designable mention maddie cawthorn oh my
god you talking about maddie cross
oh boy this is crazy i think we've we've
got a video
what what is it do you have that link
what is the what is this video that
you're gonna send me
um so it appears to be in a like a car
or something because we know this week
we know this week he got caught with a
loaded firearm and an airport this is
the second time right um not only that
uh it is it was revealed over the
weekend
um well i guess it was actually a week
ago today
that he was on a royal caribbean cruise
and he was caught in pictures wearing a
bra i guess which what is nothing
nothing
just it just it seems to go against all
the rhetoric that madison clawthorne
actually says there was another video of
him out there maybe smoking a blunt or
cigar
and there's there's a lot of video out
there of him and one of his aides i
forget his name off hand i think it's
steven
smith or something like that i'm not
real sure i i might i might have got
that name wrong but is one of his aides
uh went to amsterdam with him
and they were they were releasing a lot
of video that way it seems like to me
that republicans are behind this not not
the the lib extreme democrats that it's
the republicans that are actually trying
to destroy
madison gotham now some people have
also i don't know if you mentioned this
one but there's also the insider trading
situation yeah too you're right what
explain that real quick um why we're on
investing
yeah uh i mean why we're on red pill
investing the quick and dirty of it is
madison cawthorne uh
he i believe it's a lawsuit right now
that is against him uh also potent or or
rather there is
uh he took an action there's a
consequence um you know decided to act
on certain information and is involved
in insider insider trading scheme um and
it is now being this is
like the the bitcoin the the let's go
right brandon
let's go brandon
because what ends up happening is there
are multiple people involved there's the
race car driver the guy that everyone's
like oh let's go brain and that all that
was the commercial where they posted the
let's go brandon coin on the right yeah
yeah on the side of the car
yeah so he did an instagram post or a
tweet i think his instagram post where
he like was like oh tomorrow's gonna be
popping off or whatever it is right and
uh then the
the race car driver you know was was
talking it up and then the coin goes
public you know it has an ico which is a
as a or uh you know it's basically like
the equivalent of an ipo but for for um
startups right for no we're not for
startups but you have an ipo for for
startups or companies but then you have
an ico for um for crypto crypto okay
that's you just just has a different
acronym because it's got a different
right right so basically he introduced
this coin for crypto and was using his
own platform to publish or to to promote
it and to upsell and to hype it up and
then you know then it becomes a whole
thing of like oh are you buying selling
you know when when are you doing these
things how much you making the whole
question so uh he took an action and now
there's a consequence you know
right and i think someone's referred him
to the ethics committee in congress for
it even um here is it it is stephen
smith is the name of the uh patriot
takes has this video right this is the
video that i've used your schedule which
is like an assistant right and he's an
aide or something like that yeah he
works he works for madison right right
exactly yeah this is the video and
steven smith is holding the phone here
and um
not to give too much away but madison
cawthorne's in the driver's seat it
appears and they kind of are making
jokes it's hard to know what they're
making jokes about but then
watch at the very end where the the
person holding the phone steven smith
right
what the what the hell passion and
desire would like to see a naked body
beneath my hands
me too all right
now i i'm actually not sure how
significant this is other than in
republican politics i i really i don't
know what they're talking about and
they're quoting a movie i have no
[ __ ] idea i have no
no idea what is being uh if this is if
he's quoting something or if he's just
you know making fun of something i have
no idea and i and i honestly i don't
know if these two are closeted and
they're they're having a homosexual
relationship which again nothing is
wrong with that if that's who you are i
mean i mean right i don't i actually
don't give a [ __ ] about that i really
don't care because that's your thing
nobody on our side cares about that [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
if if they if they are having sex right
they're boning each other if they're
having sex field orgies if he's wearing
bras i don't give a [ __ ] the thing that
gets me the most is when the hypocrisy
of it all and really it goes back to
this stupid [ __ ] boneheaded thing
that he the video that we showed
yesterday of him in the airport in dc
talking about don't accidentally carry
loaded guns in your backpack
this is your stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] like
you people running around the country
demonizing
lgbtq people and making literally
legislating them into a position where
they are ostracized from society
you are making it to where it's a
dangerous place in america for someone
to live who identifies as whatever they
want whether it's a certain person they
love a certain person they want to marry
if if if they are if they want to be a
man they want to be a woman you're
making it [ __ ] dangerous for them and
then in private in private you may or
you may not be doing the exact same
thing that you're ostracizing people for
right you
[ __ ] that's the same [ __ ] with
the gun where you're making this
offhanded joke about accidentally having
a loaded gun in a backpack and then and
then [ __ ] pointing at liberals saying
you're the reason why there's a gun
problem because there's not enough guns
and you liberals aren't strong enough
and smart enough and all this [ __ ]
which is
right which is
is so is so disgusting and so irritating
and frustrating because earlier this
week we watch a baseball game with kids
right and you hear gunfire in the
background and instead of having a place
where families and friends can get
together and watch the kids just have
fun and play baseball and you know i'm
sure you played baseball as a kid right
i remember playing baseball as a kid up
until high school and having like this
is a great moment in my life where i was
able to make friends and have great
experiences instead of dodging bullets
exactly and so the id and so the idea of
like oh liberals are the reason we have
gun problems and the only reason to
solve a a gun problem is you know a bad
guy with a more gun more guns
bullets flying everywhere has had more
bullets flying exactly you got don jr
last week you did a video on it with him
in greitens and they're shooting these
targets saying that oh liberals watch
out like i destroyed that [ __ ]
we're making we're making death threats
against a group of people and you're
just shooting a static object great for
you [ __ ] right you you shot a thing
that was that was sitting still you shot
a target great i don't give a [ __ ] but
when you start saying liberals watch out
or or were coming for you or whatever
the [ __ ] narrative might be with guns
because all of a sudden now we're just
what is this the greatest game where
we're hunting humans right what the [ __ ]
is this well and then and it's the same
hypocrisy it's the same [ __ ] when
you see madison cauldron in his aid
whether they're homosexual or not or
because really honestly i just think
they're joking i don't actually right i
don't actually believe this video is not
enough evidence for me to believe that
madison catherine or his age is
homosexuals they're not the thing that
the thing that ben shapiro's the kurt
charlie kirks the tucker carlsons of the
world are afraid of that's what that
whole tanning their balls were that
[ __ ] was is they are they are
horrified and terrified of their
insecurity of their homosexual
tendencies and they are they they
internalize them and they [ __ ]
outward project them towards people that
they hate because
oh yeah well i was sitting in my car and
we were joking about being homosexual
and that scares the ever loving [ __ ] out
of me that someone might find that out
or that i might be a homosexual because
i joked about it you do not have to just
because you joke about being homosexual
does not make you one and who gives a
[ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] leave these
[ __ ] people alone and stop being such
[ __ ] hypocrites and by the way
madison got thorn by the way you can eat
[ __ ] is what you can do you can eat [ __ ]
and you cannot be in congress because
you do not need to be anywhere near any
kind of lever of power not just because
you were you were a [ __ ] bigot but
because you were a [ __ ] crooked piece
of [ __ ] with your insider trading thank
you uh
mj for the super chat there we really
appreciate you joining in every day you
want to hear the jingle we're going to
do the jingles we're gonna do the
generals today of the week um let's go
one more let's go to the uh alpha cuck
first oh
speaking of ben shapiro we just talked
about the alpha ben shapiro benny boy
being completely terrified of his
homosexual tendencies i mean absolutely
terrified of sexual sexuality
terrified terrified that a woman that a
woman would be aroused gabe
and be and be terrified be terrified
of someone's speech because we've seen
we've seen the video where he blocked
someone's speech i think that's why he's
the yeah yeah yeah is it i mean
yes that is that is 100 why he is on the
list there and you know just from just
to want to remind everyone ben shapiro
is the type of guy that when he walks
into the room he dries it all up he just
so he just sucks the moisture right out
of the room
let me show you left with a dry ass
[ __ ] let me see if i can find this
video of uh ben shapiro here uh drying
up the room uh
as it were big thank you to kathy
oh yeah thank you kevin super sticker
here is the clip let me get it forwarded
here to where they uh
to where they where they don't like the
free speech here's the clip now to give
context and this is a clip of ben
shapiro speaking and this this person is
a a outright woker as uh he he probably
walks into the pool with the stairs and
he probably eats you know vegetables and
stuff um but what happens here at the
end is ben shapiro is trying to shut him
up and they actually take the microphone
away from so much so that they're
putting their hands in front of it not
letting them speak like you know
hampering is freedom of speech yeah
they're silencing they're suppressing
right let's see the republican party
wouldn't do that no absolutely not well
the video of course is gonna take a
little bit to load of course what the
hell is going on
uh the internet here i actually thought
gabe i told you this morning that there
were storms here i didn't know yeah i'd
lose power or not but i haven't it was
gonna it was gonna be like it was gonna
be the gabe sanchez show today yeah i
know well here well you know it happens
here here's here's it well anyways the
damn video isn't working uh here i'll
i'll download it and i'll upload it well
um
let's let's uh um because basically what
happens is let me refresh here let me
see if i can refresh and get but anyways
what happens in the video
is that this person is speaking and he's
speaking about wokeness and being woke
and what and that the right wing like
ben shapiro always defines it as the
wrong [ __ ] thing like
like uh here here now it's working let's
see oh it's working okay i think i just
downloaded it for you man
here it is
okay so we're gonna have to we're gonna
have to stop here because this is going
nowhere but what's up
i'm gonna have to stop with this with
you because this is going nowhere and me
and he means because we talked about
this the other he means it's going
nowhere because it's not helping his
narrative and he really he's gonna lose
the argument here so he wants to shut
this guy up but watch what happens
physically is
all the free speech advocates in the
crowd are trying to silence it now look
look here they're holding their hand
physically over the microphone
as you get the mic you're right right
cover the mic
elon musk's free speech here this is
elon musk style free speech if you want
to know so that is why ben shapiro uh
ended up on the um if you don't say what
we like then we silence your speech
that's right that's right that's why ben
shapiro ended up as the alpha cuck
because
he does he does cuck a lot
um
and it happens it happens
now we go to ultimately uh our winner
who is marjorie taylor green or marjorie
perjury green i used to call her marjory
hoop foot green yeah maybe but
yeah marjorie or perjury taylor green
yeah boy we have a lot of we do we have
a lot of video on oh boy our video does
not stop where where do we want to start
do we want to start with the video that
she posted that she thought was a good
idea to post online yeah we do that one
maybe we played the other video that i
found this week you know uh oh yeah yeah
yeah okay well let's let's start let me
see if i can find the one uh what has
happened give people context here this
video that she posted where she she's
walking appears she's walking down the
the sidewalk
at the united states capital um and a
reporter named john acosta is approaches
her now she
she acts as if
um he's following her and she says like
don't
don't um
don't don't follow me or something like
that what what is she saying in this
video what she was uh
well by the end of the video she's
telling acosta be like you're harassing
me this is harassment you're harassing
me he's like i'm just asking you a
question right i'm just asking you a
[ __ ] question um which he's entitled
to do which um let's see uh there's one
video which video do you want i want the
i want the the one where that he
approaches her in the street uh
here i i got i got it here i got it here
okay let's let's see we got it here here
is the video where he is he's he's a
reporter he's a journalist here um and
she's on a public sidewalk and he has
the right to ask her questions she
doesn't have she doesn't have to answer
but he has the right to ask her
you also i guess you also said
you didn't recall calling nancy pelosi a
traitor now the context here too is this
video is being recorded by one of her
staff members i guess is that right is
that what's going on here yeah yeah this
is there seems to be
this is marjory taylor green's video
like this is her
her aide is recording this video
uh
with the belief that this is going to
make margaret taylor green seem more
sane oh yeah okay well let's see
how sane she seems
you know jim
i don't seem to recall
what's going on there
you know jim
you have a show and he does have a show
what what does that matter i mean i
guess that's actually kind of the point
is he does have a show
um but she goes on to say here um you
know and and they look through the text
message this is like four minutes long
i'm not going to play the whole thing
but let's play a little more and let's
get to the part where he's looking up
the text message watch what she says
all fairness you try to present this
image of me to your viewers
he tries to present well we're just
trying to get some answers did you send
a text
asking for the president to declare
martial law did you read it you know i
don't recall those being my text
messages but have you read the text
message that is
that you're referring to i did because
it actually says if you it was
misspelled but it's just
you're a [ __ ] idiot but yeah it does
it does seem to say um and and she's
she's trying to what she's trying to
frame up here which he's not gonna be
able to do in a court of law if this
ends up being in the court of law for
perjury um which i don't know if it will
or not i'm not real sure how that
administrative hearing works and her
being under oath down there i'm not sure
um in georgia that that we streamed
eight hours last week and you can go to
the youtube channel and subscribe to the
youtube channel and see
that that footage we actually did a cut
of the footage but it leaves in almost
the majority of her testimony that day
down in georgia on her staying on the
ballot or being taken off the ballot but
and that's what he's talking about here
is is this the the text message that has
been revealed after she testified on the
stand that she did not call for martial
law which the text messages proves that
she did that's why she's being so
offhanded here right like she's like oh
what did you read them did you read them
because they might say or might not say
and i don't recall if i sent them i mean
it says that i sent them but it's on
cnn.com or something let's listen
if you read it correctly jim your
problem is you're lying again right now
you can't read it i do not know on those
things that's what that text message
is
why don't you be honest why even bring
it up why didn't you bring up marshall
you know your problem is you're just
one of those liars on television and
people hate it they can't stand the
liars they can't stand they can't stand
people telling the truth when they don't
want to hear the truth that's what she's
saying that's what she's saying
i'm not the one saying i don't know i
don't recall it well the supposed text
message require
i don't
the only way to save our republic is for
trump to call for marshall so she text
the only way for to save our republic is
for trump to call for martial law so
she's calling on trump to call for
martial law but then she's debating the
the the the words after i don't know
about those things and come on yeah
she's like what does this text say i
don't know about this thing
right i don't know on those things i
just wanted you to tell him i don't know
on this thing is that what that says it
says i don't know on this thing but why
are you bringing it up she makes it seem
like she well she believes that she's
making a point here right right well
she's getting very defensive
about these text messages that were
supposedly allegedly sent from marjory
taylor green okay this is someone who
has clearly supported the insurrection
and overthrowing the government and uh
you know rejecting
the certification
of votes for
the election
you know and then at the end of that she
has the audacity and i and i think he'll
show the video in a second but she has
the audacity to claim and accuse jim
acosta of harassing when he just asked
me questions he claimed it and but i
want to show you video here gabe right
of the same thing that martin she's
claiming that this was harassment but i
want to show here joe joe actually uh
jojo from jurors post this while
marjorie taylor green is accusing jim
acosta of stalking and harassing her for
asking questions about martial law a
reminder she both stalked and harassed
david hogg a survivor of the deadly high
school shooting right
the the
shooting at marjory stoneman douglas
down in florida
and david hogg was in washington d.c
this is before she was actually
a congressperson this was before she was
elected to congress she was following
him around the city um and and saying
these things so if
jim acosta a reporter and journalist
calling and are following her and asking
questions near the capitol is harassment
i wonder what this is why are you
supporting the red flag laws
but by the way david hogg is actually in
washington dc at this time to to go to
congress which is his right again to
lobby members as a private citizen i i
believe um or maybe even part of an
organization but to go to washington to
lobby members of congress for gun safety
and she is mad that he is
this is what she's mad at this kid david
at this time is in high school right i
just survived a school shooting from
high school he was dodging bullets right
and she's mad she's mad that she doesn't
have the right to go into high schools
our people doesn't have the right to go
in high schools to sling bullets at high
school students and he's trying he's
there to try to stop
gun violence at high schools and mass
shootings in high schools and she hates
him for it listen
if scott peterson the resource officer
at parkland had done his job then
nicholas cruz wouldn't have killed
anybody in your high school or at least
protected them jesus so in other words
what she's saying as long as as long as
another person shoots another human
being then then
forget about forget about cruz actually
getting the gun or or being able to have
access to it again forget about that
forget about that
lay that
lay that problem aside for a second the
problem really is is that there wasn't
enough gunfire really right that's the
problem it's it's like if we analyze the
situation it's not the fact of yeah the
source or where the source came like
it's we're not gonna i i address this
systemically and and fix the problem
we're just gonna put a band-aid on it
and say well the real problem not the
actual problem but they're a belief from
what the real problem is and then she
goes and she harasses this teenager
who's literally you can see like
look i'm not gonna show the whole video
but look she's following around across
crosswalks uh in into different areas of
the city and this is not and the thing
is like this type of behavior from
audrey taylor green is not new like
she's been doing this like you look at
when she was running in a race in
georgia
the person that she was running against
had to drop out because of one the
goddamn q
followers that were harassing stalking
death threats and margaret taylor green
said nothing she was in full support you
know he was one that didn't say a thing
you remember this video a while back
where the democrats were trying to take
a picture on the uh on the capitol steps
and she was yelling and screaming vile
[ __ ] things while they were just
trying to take a picture like she is
harassing the [ __ ] out of them she has
just issues they're just trying to take
a picture like i don't know if she needs
anger management or she needs some sort
of therapy but marjorie taylor green has
one too many screws loose in her head
she could use a cold pair of handcuffs
around her wrist probably actually is
cool oh yeah but
um let's go to this next video because
this is the one that uh
actually gave us our title for today
jamie raskin destroys marge is that
right is this the one where she makes
comments and jamie raskin basically
burns her to the ground is that what
this video is this is it okay let's this
is about two minutes and 20 seconds so
let's
we're gonna watch this whole thing
because jamie raskin absolutely destroys
her here tacked it's a shame it's a
tragedy i yield back the remainder of
reserve
gentlemen gentlewoman's times expired
gentleman from pennsylvania reserves
gentlemen from maryland is recognized mr
speaker the united states of america
just witnessed witnessed the most
astonishing spectacle
we are here to debate
aid to the people of ukraine defending
themselves against a massive invasion by
vladimir putin and his army
then
the minority puts up the distinguished
general lady from georgia who does not
mention ukraine once
she does not mention the thousands of
ukrainian civilians who've been
slaughtered by putin's army she does not
mention more than 100 ukrainian children
who've been shot and killed by the
ukrainian army instead she talks about a
massive invasion
at the border a massive invasion which
their own speakers have said today
hundreds of thousands of people have
been apprehended it
that's very different from a military
invasion the one in ukraine of course
the gentlelady's not going to talk about
that
she had a lot to say the other day when
she heckled me continuously
when i came to the floor it was like the
rocky horror picture show in here with
her chanting about the russia hoax and
russia this and russia that now she had
the opportunity to tell the world what
her views about russia are i put them
out there exactly what she has said she
said that the aid that the taxpayers of
america are sending to the people of
ukraine to defend themselves against
vladimir putin and the russian army
falls into the hands of nazis i want to
see her proof
where's our evidence
she talks about
nato nazis
does my minority believe that our allies
in nato who are trying to defend the
people of ukraine are nazis has it come
to this
general lady talked about a massive
invasion we had a massive invasion of
our own chamber
and she continued to be a cheerleader
for the insurrection
and deny what happened here
so at the very end there um and you
don't hear it on this uh particular
video but at the very end someone stands
up and asks for for his comments about
the insurrection to be stricken from the
record forget about all the other stuff
they well i mean they want his whole his
whole statement but they're very
concerned about the insurrection
statement and the reason why
the reason why is because that's part of
the [ __ ] conversation they're having
down and the judges making decision in
georgia the administrative judge that we
watched last week for eight hours on a
live stream make a decision about her
being on the ballot whether she's an
insurrectionist or not and jamie raskin
puts it in public record right there not
only that she he absolutely burns her to
the ground um which is fantastic this
this [ __ ] nonsense where they run
around spreading putin's propaganda all
over the place um it's no wonder that
they're against making sure that the
american people aid the ukrainians in
their fight against a murderous dictator
who wants to take away their sovereign
nation and their democracy by by by the
house debating 33 billion dollars that
president biden wants to make sure that
we help defend ukraine but not just
ukraine but democracy all around the
world because that's the thing that
putin is doing he's and he
biden has said it time and time again
putin is not anyone's [ __ ] friend
because he is out to destroy democracy
yes he's doing it to ukraine because
that's one of the closest democracies
that he can actually launch bombs in and
commit war crimes in but he is hell-bent
on doing that everywhere and and the
united states and and president biden
and it looks like the house and
hopefully the senate will get off their
ass to do this will aid them in 33
billion dollars but marjorie taylor
green is coming to the floor of the
house to argue
that putin's good and you shouldn't use
33 billion dollars to help defend
democracy
doesn't even mention does not mention
ukraine right the whole the whole topic
is like can we should we give a right to
ukraine to defend their democracy and
make sure that this genocide uh doesn't
actually go forward right they actually
have some defense like
i don't know that's not a crazy idea uh
well she just does the normal racist
things and and talks about brown people
on the border coming across right
and that's the other thing earlier this
week she goes on that video and says the
catholic church is actually run by satan
and actually we should be good
christians and they believe christians
are those who care for for people who
are seeking refuge which is like that's
literally in the bible that's literally
what jesus taught he said you know put
shelter you know give them food you know
give them give them security you know
care for love your love thy neighbor
like this is something that is is
completely hypocritical of the
republican party and this is another
example we've got a dictator committing
genocide against ukrainians putin is
killing ukrainians and marjorie taylor
green goes well is putin
really the bad guy and it's like right
what are you what are you is he eating
dogs does he eat dogs you don't you
don't that's right does he does he eat
dogs uh you know does he do this did he
make you did he make your your boss fire
you because at the end of the day it is
that moment of like you're looking at
someone who is killing others which
just stop the just stop it right there
like that should not that no one should
be okay with that war crimes i mean
right and what she's saying in this
moment is like well you know uh it's
justified like it's [ __ ] random but
that's what the border but the border
like we have to worry about you know you
know what's funny about that uh before
we go to more hypocrisy here because i
want to point out the hypocrisy in this
video that you found somewhere on the
deep deep dark web i think um
but donald trump was supposed to fix the
board do you remember that you're
supposed to build a wall in the
numerator yeah and he said mexico was
going to pay for it yeah i think anyways
anyways uh speaking of hypocrites my
family in mexico uh laughs at that [ __ ]
all the time because you're like it's a
big fan they're like we're not paying
for that [ __ ] yeah you can kiss my ass
um here's a video that you found
somewhere on the deep dart wed possibly
of marjorie taylor green perjuring
yourself but also maybe receiving some
information in her ear during your
testimony last friday let's listen in do
you advocate for president trump to
impose martial law as a way to remain in
power marge tell him i don't recall mrs
you've had your disagreements with
speaker pelosi isn't that right do we
have an answer huh i need to give her an
answer what are you doing i'm keeping a
count of how many times she says she
can't recall while i wait for matt gates
to text me the question wait wait why is
matt gates texting you the question you
said we needed a man on the inside yeah
as in a cameraman to give us a live feed
oh
yeah i should probably tell gates he can
take up his bull profession oh my god
just tell me if she said it uh i don't
think so marge just say no i haven't
said that
okay put up pennies exhibit five please
where is the lawyer going with this oh
no she did what and she liked a facebook
comment that said a bullet to the head
would be quicker in order to remove
house speaker nancy pelosi oh [ __ ] uh
marge tell him oh no wait
hold on now that was close oh nice guess
what what she beat eric trump's record
so i don't know where you found this
video at but this is great video
evidence of her hypocrisy yeah yeah i
mean i would not be surprised if she
actually had a had a uh uh earpiece in
would you i would
i would be saying
they accuse democrats of it all the time
and it's typical projection i don't know
all i'm going to say is on the on the
situation that happened during that that
that hearing she was very quick to
answer certain things now obviously she
was probably coached to say certain
things but the response that she had to
certain questions
i almost
want to say
she had someone talking to her ear with
a little earpiece maybe maybe i don't
know well that's how you that's the your
earpieces the new ear pieces that you
have those are soros earpieces right
yeah these are coming straight from
george soros okay good and every time i
talk i just hear like ching chi ching
ching okay it seems just deposited oh
that's good that's good yeah yeah okay
that's good that's good yeah well we all
need that let's give let's give the
bonehead of the week her do here let's
mj wanted to hear the jingle so here we
go
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah marjorie taylor green is the bone
end of the week again thank you everyone
for participating in the bone end of the
week go follow at tonymichaelspod on
twitter to find the poll of bone of the
week and subscribe to the youtube
channel because it sounds like the chat
is gonna make gabe sanchez our executive
producer and the runner the runner and
executor of the bone of the week pull
and the graphics put it up on youtube i
heard i heard a couple i heard a couple
people in the chat say not everyone has
twitter so i will
accommodate the youtube population um
but you know if you want more people to
vote on the poll make sure to share the
video make sure to subscribe
like get the word out do all those
things do all those things for us here
and this has been this has been your
addition don't stick around we're going
to have a couple announcements right
after this this has been your edition
because you voted and we broke it down a
bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa
that was sort of a good transition boom
i didn't even see it i was like
bam i was too distracted by those faces
flying all over the screen and the next
thing i knew you were there and it was
back to the old screen i know i know
it's great i i love bone in the week and
the reason why i love bone of the week
is because you guys get to decide this
you guys get to vote we never know
really what you're gonna do now
sometimes like this week we put marge on
there i actually i predicted on the
podcast pages i thought elon musk would
win but i did
i voted for elon too [ __ ] that bonehead
but here's the thing you guys get to
decide the bone of the week and we break
it down and here's also what we're going
to do we're going to start to cut out
bone and we've done it several times
before where we cut it out on its own
and we're gonna put it on youtube but
we're also gonna air it on midas touch
facebook page if you're out there on
facebook and i think we're just gonna
air it on youtube twitter and twitch all
at the same time and just give everyone
the opportunity on sundays we're gonna
pick a time maybe we'll experiment with
it eventually we'll get a specific time
that we can tell you when it's on and
it'll be a live air or a live re-era
opponent a week right in case you miss
it or in case you want to re-watch the
bone of the week yeah we really and
you're like i just want to watch these
two [ __ ] on these people again right
that's fantastic just rake them through
the muck rake them through the muck
especially when it's marjorie tater
green because it was very obvious to me
in the beginning that she was gonna win
so make sure to vote on
on twitter follow us on twitter at
tonymichaelspod vote there for bone of
the week make sure you see the we
usually put it out on thursdays because
it takes us that long during the week to
figure out who the bone ends are there's
a lot of donuts check out youtube the
polls right there
the poll is going to be on youtube we'll
put it up there so subscribe to the
youtube channel don't forget the sub
over there
and really uh what we're going to do too
we're working on a best of thing for the
weekend gabe for saturdays where we put
a best of the tony michaels podcast up
on the youtube twitter twitch and the
mindsets facebook page also the
directories don't forget
bone of the week will be separate now on
its own on the directors you'll be able
to download it on sundays and the best
of show on saturdays so now you can
download the tony michaels podcast
seven
days a week
gabe no
give me that sweet sweet juicy content
seven days of [ __ ] week you are going
to be able to download the tony michaels
podcast on your favorite directories
apple spotify google wherever you get
your podcast but here's the thing gabe
here's the thing we will always
always air the show live on youtube
twitter twitch and now the mind is touch
facebook page
every single weekday monday through
friday everyone have a great weekend and
until monday because we will be here
live for two hours on monday as we are
every single weekday until then surf's
up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking